[Música]
quisiera empezar contándoles lo que
significó para mí correr mis primeros 21
kilómetros como muchas personas saben en
la modalidad de atletismo existen
diferentes categorías
existen cinco 10 15 21 ó 42 km entre
otros hace un tiempo venía entrenando
para lo que serían mis primeros 21
kilómetros y en el 2017 decide
inscribirme con mi papá a la media
maratón acá bogotá el recorrido a esta
carrera es muy lindo porque lo lleva a
uno por calles muy concurridas acá en
bogotá sales del parque simón bolívar
buscando la calle 26 llegas hasta la
carrera séptima bajas por la calle 94
hasta agarrar la carrera 30 para volver
al parque simón bolívar
al ser las calles tan concurridas se
instalan familiares amigos o personas
que simplemente van pasando por ahí
hacerle barra a cada una de las personas
que van en la carrera eso realmente es
muy lindo como cada carrera es personal
salí con mi papá sin embargo cada uno
inició su propio recorrido yo ya iba más
o menos como en la calle 26 con carrera
séptima
eso aproximadamente es el kilómetro 5
cuando voltea mirar lleve a una chica
vestida de rojo sola y tirada en el piso
por cómo se veían sus ojos y su aspecto
estaba completamente intoxicado
mientras cada uno de nosotros iba
corriendo su propia carrera en ese
momento mis piernas siguieron corriendo
sin embargo me trasladé hace unos años
atrás en donde era yo quien estaba ahí
sola y tirada en el piso en la calle
hace aproximadamente 10 años había
llegado a la estadística de las 9 mil
538 personas que llegan a la calle según
el den el censo del dane del 2017 en las
cuales pasé días llenos de hambre
soledad e incertidumbre sin embargo la
calle me enseñó y aprendí que por más
situaciones difíciles que hayan siempre
nos envía personas dispuestas a
gritarnos que sí podemos
tal cual lo escuchado en la carrera si
vas a llegar a la meta también que sea
lo que no sea que crea dios las
estrellas la vida siempre nos envía
personas que se convierten en ángeles
los cuales están dispuestos a ayudarnos
a sobrellevar cada una de las
situaciones difíciles que tenemos en
esta vida
también aprendí que una de las mejores
cosas que podría llegar a hacer era como
era cultivar mi comunicación interna
porque había días que pensaba que me iba
a morir había otros que pensaba que
simplemente estaba en un muy mal sueño y
había otro que me recordaba todo lo que
yo había querido hacer de pequeña y
siempre lo había querido alcanzar conocí
muchas personas que llegan a la calle
realmente no hay una única razón
problemas económicos en la casa o con la
familia o situaciones muy muy difíciles
pero dentro de todas ellas entendí que
uno de los problemas principales era la
falta de comunicación interna con la
familia o con la pareja con el jefe
etcétera así que empecé a pensar que
quizás mi mejor droga podría llegar a
ser la comunicación
hoy en día llevo 10 años de recuperación
ha sido algo constante y nunca ha sido
una línea recta y aprendí que por más
tropiezos que he tenido jamás ha sido un
retroceso hay días realmente en los que
siento que voy a estancada pero sigo y
siempre voy adelante en ese momento
volvía a mi cabeza y ya iba llegando a
la carrera 30 terminando prácticamente
la carrera en ese momento iba llorando
porque recordé que en esos momentos en
donde mis ojos solamente veían oscuridad
jamás pensé volver a pisar una
universidad y me grado de hoy en día soy
ingeniero industrial tampoco jamás pensé
estar corriendo al lado de millones de
personas con una camisa azul
fosforescente terminando lo que sería mi
primera media maratón y entendí que cada
uno lleva su propia carrera hay algunas
que son cortitas y logramos llegar a la
meta hay otras que parecen eternas pero
ese camino nos enseñan grandes
aprendizajes y hay otras que quizás
jamás jamás podamos terminar y sea eso
lo que vinimos a aprender en esta vida
al final cuando llegue a la meta estaba
mi mamá
estaba mi papá y mis hermanas
recordándome que uno de los mejores
idiomas del amor es la comunicación
[Música]